con algunos anuncios concretos y sobre
todo buenas intenciones terminó aquí en
París esta primera Cumbre para hacer un
orden financiero mundial más justo y
solidario una idea del presidente Manuel
macron que nació en la última cop en
Egipto justamente el primer gran logro
fue repactar la deuda de zambia el
primer país africano que cayó en cese de
pago tras la crisis del covid 19 en el
año 2020 para eso fue necesario negociar
con china que hoy es el principal
acreedor del mundo sobre todo entre los
países pobres o en vías de desarrollo
sino importantes se concreta esa
transferencia de fondos del fondo
monetario internacional de los países
ricos a los países pobres se acordó
también tras el Coby 19 Eran cien mil
millones de dólares que finalmente van a
ser transferidos hay diez proyectos en
la lista también se concreta el fondo
que se acordó en la copa 21 aquí en
París en el año 2015 de 100 mil millones
de dólares para que los países en vías
de desarrollo más pobres se puedan
adaptar a las consecuencias del cambio
climático el Banco Mundial también
confirmó que pondrá un dólar por cada
dólar invertido por los privados en los
países en vías de desarrollo o pobres
también es una manera de garantizar esas
inversiones y se aumenta a 200 mil
millones de dólares la capacidad de
préstamo de los bancos multilaterales se
echó de menos un acuerdo sobre una
posible tasa un posible impuesto a las
transacciones financieras o al
transporte marítimo son temas que han
quedado en carpetas según el presidente
Manuel macron que podrán evaluarse
quizás cuando se realice el primer
balance de esta Cumbre y de los acuerdos
dentro de seis meses